Let's get started on this by looking at the test cases instead of the code.
Our buggy program worked fine when row 0 had the duplicates,
but it didn't work well when row 1 had the duplicates.
So, probably we're not handling the row correctly.
Let's go up and see if that intuition pans out. In fact, it does.
We're looping over all of the rows in range size.
But if you look down in this code, although we introduced the variable row, we never really use it.
Just use it over here. We're not using in all that much.
Remember, I want to check to see that all of the numbers in these row are unique within that row.
Conceptually, that's two references to row and I only see one over here.
The bug in this code is that we're always checking the 0 true board.
We should be checking the current row against itself,
and that single word fix causes us to get the answers as we works on.